je reçois donc que valérie mandron
chargée de relations entreprises
coordinatrice pédagogique et pour
l'établissement blanche de castille auch
mails l'établissement qui va ouvrir ce
sera en septembre une filière design
graphique un bts en alternance ça
n'existait pas jusqu alors dans le
département des yvelines
en quoi cela consiste bonsoir et merci
déjà de me recevoir alors ça ça consiste
en fait avec des élèves qui vont sortir
de bac arts appliqués on a déjà une
section sur blanche de castille qui
s'appelle std2a ou bien des bacs
généraux qui auront fait une mise à
niveau en arts appliqués
donc ça va consister en une alternance
d'une semaine en entreprise une semaine
en une petite formation à blanche de
castille et ça s'adresse à un public de
jeunes qui ont un petit peu assez des
études classiques et qui ont besoin
d'avoir quelque chose de concret donc
ils vont pouvoir travailler directement
tout le tout la formation théorique
qu'ils apprendront à l'unité de
formation et de pouvoir l'appliquer en
entreprise voilà votre établissement
déjà tendance à mettre l'accent sur le
domaine artistique il existe déjà une
section arts appliqués dès la seconde
pour guitare batterie arts appliqués
donc voila et donc c'est un petit peu
pourquoi nous avions envie d'ouvrir
encore vers un autre public de pouvoir
donc offrir cette cette proposition de
bts graphique donc là ça va être
vraiment des étudiants qui vont
justement pouvoir intégrer intégrer un
cursus avec une formation qualifiante
immédiate puisque à l'issue des deux
années de formation en alternance
ils passeront en bts comment va se
dérouler ce bts quels sont les
enseignements en fait qu'ils sont tout
simplement proposé puis aussi on va
parler des débouchés après alors
l'enseignement va avoir il va y avoir
quelques matières générales bien
évidemment culture générale un petit peu
de langues vivantes mais bien évidemment
on va surtout mettre l'accent sur tout
ce qui est ce tu d'autres studios de
création tout ce qui va être atelier
recherche de projets travailler sur des
logiciels
on voit là les étudiants vont vraiment
être en pratique on va dire c'est une
filière ce design graphique qui ensuite
permet de trouver facilement
alors les débouchés quels sont les mais
alors oui bien sûr que ça permet de
trouver facilement un travail déjà parce
que vous avez deux ans de d'enseignement
et de pratique en entreprise
ce deuxième ans et que on est vers l'ère
du numérique l'a en outre notre bts et
communication et médias numériques
donc les jeunes travaillant sur mac et
donc ce pour vous se diriger vers des
métiers tels que webmaster tels que
graphiste tels que 20 tous les métiers
qui tournent autour du numérique
aujourd'hui tout ce qui est à bhl est
numérique
aujourd'hui toutes les sociétés ont
besoin de communiquer de cette façon là
c'est de l'alternance ça veut dire qu'il
faut des entreprises est ce que vous
avez déjà des contacts avec ces
entreprises est ce que vous avez des
pistes aussi pour ces jeunes qui
voudraient rejoindre l'établissement
mais qui n'ont pas forcément l'idée de
l'entreprise qui pourraient les
accueillir
alors bien évidemment ça fait aussi
partie de l'émission que de trouver des
entreprises et des partenaires je suis
en plein dans ce travail et j'ai déjà
l'accueil de pas mal de dents
d'entreprises et par ailleurs si
l'apprenti je vais appeler ça les
étudiants apprentis arrive avec un
projet et une société nous
l'accueillerons avec mais avec
bienveillance
commençons me reçoivent les entreprises
justement ce genre d'initiative de créer
des bts de créer des formations en
alternance ils sont prêts à accueillir
tous ces jeunes le contexte est
difficile donc ça reste compliqué aussi
pour parce qu'ils sont rémunérés aussi
sait jamais alors ces jeunes se
rémunérer avec un pourcentage sur le
smic en fonction de leur âge et il faut
savoir aussi que le conseil général aide
les entreprises dont qu'ils ont ils ont
une
une prime on va dire comme ça et ils ont
une exonération des charges patronales
et salariales donc c'est un vrai plus
pour l'entreprise qui plus est
l'entreprise peut former un jeune à son
éthique à sa façon de travailler et donc
au départ perdre un petit peu de temps
parce qu'on en ait un
on est sur l'information du jeune mais
finalement pour pouvoir en gagner
puisque on garde notre jeune pendant
deux années et ont regardé en souriant à
l'issue des deux ans et donc de
reprendre un autre mandat c'est de les
conserver par la suite combien d'élèves
vous vous attendez quels sont les
profils recherchés un petit peu alors on
attend maximum 15 élèves on voudrait
vraiment une formation très qualitative
et un suivi personnalisé pour chacun de
nos étudiants et comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure ce sont des profils des
jeunes qui ont un bac obligatoirement
soit un bac arts appliqués soit un bac
général avec une mise à niveau en arts
appliqués
on va leur demander une lettre de
motivation on va les recevoir un
entretien avec un dossier de travaux
personnels
on va étudier avec eux leurs besoins
leurs envies et surtout leur projet
professionnel pouvant les accompagner au
mieux notamment dans les entreprises
qu'on leur proposera qu'est ce que vous
mettez en avant pour les pour les
séduire justement pour les faire venir
parce que là ça débute tout juste donc
les candidatures commencent à arriver
pour recevoir un maximum de candidatures
vous leur direz quoi ce soir ce sont des
filières qui embauchent que c'est de
l'alternance qu'on est déjà dans une
entreprise
voilà vous avez répondu à ma question
effectivement ce sont on est vraiment
dans l'ère du numérique donc aujourd'hui
c'est le travail est hélas deuxièmement
c'est vraiment une formation qualifiante
immédiate et la plus part du jeune des
jeunes aujourd'hui on fait trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans d'études et parfois
se retrouvent sur le marché de travail
130 sans emploi beaucoup de demandes
déjà on a démarré notre ouverture depuis
un mois et demi et on commence à voir
quelques demande effectivement on va
peut-être en profiter aussi pour
conclure pour parler de votre
établissement blanche de kaïs bande
blanche de castille pardon établissement
particulier puisque vous accueillez les
c'est à dire pas de la naissance mais
presque volailles vivantes
on a deux sites en alcide pasteur où
vous avez la maternelle à la primaire et
après le site bel air où on a le collège
le lycée est donc la filière arts
appliqués et et une classe préparatoire
et hypokhâgne et khâgne les élèves sont
assez fidèles
quand il commence à blanc louis bien
fermé vendredi parce qu'on s'y sent bien
dans cet établissement
merci à vous je rappelle que le bts
design graphique va ouvrir en septembre
vous pouvez bien évidemment contacter
l'établissement si vous souhaitez
intégrer cette formation merci à vous
merci